that light that you are seeing on one of  those little specks  has been traveling for  over 13 billion years  [Music]  if you held a  grain of sand  on the tip of your finger at arm's  length  that is the part of the universe that  you're seeing just one little speck of  the universe  [Music]  liftoff from a tropical rainforest to  the edge of time  a voyage back itself the birth of the  universe  it's a new window into the history of  our universe  light from other worlds orbiting stars  far beyond our own light where stars  were born  and from where they die  light from the oldest galaxies the  oldest documented light in the history  of the universe  and when you look at something as big as  this is  we are going to be able to answer  questions that we don't even know what  the questions are yet  this is what's happening  you